[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العلوي
روسيا تلوح بتحالف عسكري جديد وكيف تنشئ
وحدات خاصه في الجيش تحسبا لنقل الدبابات
الغربيه
ايران تهدد بالانسحاب من معاهده حظر
الانتشار النووي وبتصنيف الجيوش الاوروبيه
ارهابيه
اشتباكات بين القوات الصوماليه وحركه
الشباب في مجاديشو والحركه تعلن سيطرتها
على مقر البلد
في بريطانيا من قبل عصابات اجراميه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه في ظل الجدل
المتواصل حول تسليم دبابات المتطوره الى
اوكرانيا من عدمه هددت روسيا اليوم على
لسان نائب رئيس مجلس الامن بظهور تحالف
عسكري جديد من الدول التي طالتها
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن في الاتحاد الروسي
روسيا او الى تدميرها
لا يدعوا مجال للشك في ان اعداء روسيا
يحاولون ارهاقها او ربما تدميرها
رئيس مجلس الدومه الروسيه كلاب بولدين قال
من جهته ان تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه لشني
ضربات على الاراضي الروسيه سيؤدي الى
كارثه عالميه
وحذر فولودين واشنطن ودول الناتو من تسليم
هذه الاسلحه وقال ان ذلك سيقود الى رد
مختلف باستخدام اسلحه اقوى من جانب روسيا
رئيس الوزراء البولندي
انتقد قرار المانيا عدم تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات لا يقعد ووصف الموقف بانه غير
مقبول وقال رئيس وزراء بولندا انه اذا
رفضت برلين اوكرانيا بالدبابات
فسيتم تشكيله صغير من الدول المستعده
للتبرع ببعض معداتها الحديثه بينها
الدبابه مشيرا الى ان القناه الى الروسيه
ما تزال تستهدف اهداف المدنيه وتقتل
الاوكرانيين بينهم النساء والاطفال
قصر الاليزيه اعلنا عن اجراء الرئيس
الفرنسي منويل ماكرون محادثات مع المستشار
الالماني اولاف شورز ضمن اطار مجلس
الوزراء الفرنسي الالماني بعد تاجيل هذا
الاجتماع لاكثر من ثلاثه اشهر
ويهدف الاجتماع لتعميق التعاون في مجالات
الامن والصناعه والطاقه وفقا بيان
الاليزيه الذي اوضح ايضا ان مجلس الوزراء
المشترك يعملوا على تقريب المواقف
الفرنسيه والالمانيه على الساحتين
الاوروبيه والدوليه وبالاخص اجراءات دعم
اخرى
المستشار الالماني جدد من جهته استمرار
بلاده في تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا طالما كان
ذلك ضروريا
سنستمر في تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا طالما
كان ذلك الضروريا وبشكل كامل سنبقى معا
كاروبيين ندافع عن مشروع السلام الاوروبي
العربيه اهلا وسهلا بك نشاط الخامسه ما
الذي املا هذا اللقاء وهذا الاجتماع حسين
بعد تاجيله المتكرر لمده ثلاثه اشهر
نعم في الواقع الاجتماع الذي اتاجل كان
يفترض ان ينعقد في السادس والعشرين من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي في سانتام لو
قرب باريس لكنه لم ينعقد وسط اعيد عنه
حينها بلقاء بين الرئيس الفرنسي والمستشار
الالماني او وحدهما بالعوده الى سؤالك ما
الذي ام لا عقد هذا الاجتماع لمجلس
الوزراء المشترك بين المانيا وفرنسا بعد
تاجيل نتيجه التوترات الذي املاه هو ان
البلدين اتفقا على الحد الادنى من المواقف
المشتركه وفي مجال الصناعات العسكريه
اتفقاه على اطلاقي منظومه عسكريه مشتركه
خصوصا ما يتعلق بطائره مقاتله مشتركه
مشتركه بين فرنسا والمانيا لكن الاتفاقات
المحدوده التاثير في هذا المجال لم تعود
عن خلافات كبيره في مجالات اخرى في كل
الاحوال الجانب الاحتفال من هذا الاجتماع
الفرنسي الالماني اا كان في جامعه
السوربون صباحا حيث حضر 300 برلماني فرنسي
والماني لاحياء الذكرى السنويه 60 لتوقيع
معاهده التعاون بين البلدين
والجانب السياسي الاقتصادي بدا هنا في قصر
الاليزا حيث انا موجود قبل حوالي ساعه من
الان سيتركز على ثلاثه محاور الاول مواجهه
التحديات البيئيه والصناعيه والاقتصاديه
خصوصا في مجال الطاقه بعد توقف روسيا عن
ضخ
الغازها الى الاوروبيين والمحور الثاني
التعاون في المجالين الدفاع والامن وهذا
كان محور خلاف بين باريس وبرلين مؤخرا
والمحور الثالث والمتعلق بمناقشات مستقبل
اوروبا في ضوء التحديات الدوليه الطالب
الموضوع الاوكراني هو الصحن اليومي لكل
الاجتماعات سواء الاوروبيه او الغربيه
ايضا بالنسبه الى الموقف من اوكرانيا
تحديدا موضوع تسليح اكياس بالدبابات
الحديثه اين يلتقي الموقف الفرنسي مع
الموقف الالماني واين يفترق
يلتقيان لناحيه اعتماد الحذر وهذا ما ترجم
في كل الاحوال في مواقف الحلفاء الغربيين
اللي اوكرانيا خلال لقائهم في قاعده
امريكيه في المانيا عندما لم يتفقوا على
تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه حديثه
يلتقيان في هذا المجال تحديدا فرنسا
والمانيا لكنهما يختلفان حول عده مسائل
اخرى اولا يختلفان بشان ما اعلنت عنه
المانيا اللي ناحيه التامين مبلغ 200
مليار يورو لتمكين الالمان من مواجهه
ارتفاع اسحار اسعار الغاز نتيجه توقف روسي
عن ضغط غاز الى الاوروبيين اعتبرت فرنسا
ان ذلك لا يندرج في سياق خطه اوروبيه
جامعه وانما هو تغليب من قبل المانيا
لمصالحها الوطنيه على حساب التضامن بين
الاوروبيين النقطه الثانيه اعلان المانيا
انها في المجال الدفاعيه ستعمد الى جعل
جيشها الاكثر تجه كان في اوروبا مع ضمان
تمويل بمائه مليار يورو للجيش الالماني
وهذا خروج على فكره ماكرون ودعوات
للاستقلال الاستراتيجي الاوروبي العسكري
والناتج بين الاوروبيين وثا في مجال
الصناعه العسكريه تتعاون المانيا لو سمحت
لي مع الولايات المتحده ومع اعضاء في
الحلف الاطلسي وحتى مع اسرائيل التي كان
يحتمل ان تتزوج المانيا بمنظومه الدفاع
بمنظومه صواريخ اسرائيليه من طراز اروس 3
وهذا ازعج الفرنسيه
طيب الموقف الالماني كان واضحا وهو ما
اغضب همم كيف بالنسبه الى باريس هل باريس
تقف وراء الموقف الالماني يعني تعارض
تزويد اكياس باسلحه حديثه مخافه من
استفزاز موسكو اكثر ام لا يعني هي تريد
تزويد اكياس باسلحه حديثه ولكن تتريه
في الواقع فرنسا كانت قناه التواصل
الوحيده كما تعلم في فتره ما مع الرئيس
الروسي بوتن كانت تحبذ الابقاء على هذه
القناه الدبلوماسيه ولم تكن متعجله ولا
متسرعه في تزويد اوكرانيا بمعدات متطوره
مساعداتها العسكريه اقتصرت على ذخيره في
فتره ما وعلى مدافع من نوع سيزار ومؤخرا
اعلنت انها سترسل لاوكرانيا دبابات قتاليه
خفيفه لكنها في الاساس كانت تحدد الابقاء
على القناه الدبلوماسيه ولكن بعد ان انقطع
التواصل بين مكه بعد اكثر من 20 اتصالات
هاتفيا بينهما منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
وبصولا الى الحادي عشر من ايلول سبتمبر من
العام الماضي عندما توقفت الاتصالات
بينهما ترى تطور على الموقف الفرنسي يؤيد
تقديم مساعدات عسكريه اوكرانيا وهذا بابا
واضحا من خلال افاده لوزير الدفاع مؤخرا
الى اوكرانيا وايضا من خلال اتص الهاتف
الاخير الذي اكد معزل الاسكي ان فرنسا
ستزود همم اوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه خفيفه
كل ذلك نعكس تطورا في الموقف الفرنسي ولكن
ليس الى حد الذهاب الى تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات قتاليه حديثه هذا تتحفظ عليه
فرنسا كما الالمان وانا اعود الى الاجابه
على سؤالين الطالب
دائما شكرا جزيلا لك حسين على كل هذه
المتابعه
في مقابل ما تزال كيف تسعى للحصول على
اسلحه متطوره مستشار الاداره رئاسيه
الاوكرانيا ميخائيل البطوله اعرب عن شعوره
بخيبه الامل بشان وضع تسليح اوكرانيا ورغم
تفاهمه للموانع التي تواجهها بعض الدول
الا ان التباطؤ في تقديم السلاح لاوكرانيا
يزيد من قتل الجنود والمدنيين الاوكرانيين
على حد قوله بدولاك شدد ايضا على اهميه
الدور الالماني القيادي في الوضع الراعي
موضحا ان 300 الى 400 من دبابات اليوبار
الالمانيه كفيله بالتفوق على ما يصل الى
ثلاثه الاف دبابه من الحقبه الصوفيه فضلا
عن مساهمتها في تشريع وتيره الحرب
هذا هو تعتبر دبابه ليوبارد الخيار
المثالي بالنسبه لاوكرانيا كونها واحده من
افضل الدبابات في العالم من ناحيه دقه
الاصابه والحمايه وخفه الحركه ورغم ان اول
نموذج من دبابات اليوبارد قد دخل الخدمه
قبل اكثر من اربعه عقود لكنها خضعت للعديد
من عمليات التطوير والتحديث وباتت الاكثر
استخداما بين دول النيترو كما تتوفر
بمختلف الطرازات ويمكن نقلها برا الى
اوكرانيا بسهوله
وتستخدم دبابات وليوبارد ذخائر حلف
الناتوبالتالي يمكن الحصول على هذه
الذخائر بكميات مناسبه من اي من دول الحلف
ويشير خبراء الى ان لا يفارد اثنان تضاهي
الدبابه الامريكيه ابرامز ام 1 من حيث
الاداء ودقه الاصابه والسرعه والامكانيات
والفرق الوحيد بينهما ان الدبابات
الامريكيه تستهلك كميات كبيره من الوقود
فيما تحتاج الدبابات الالمانيه الى الديزل
لتشغلها
معارك شرق اوكرانيا تشتد بين قوات كيف
وموسكو واوكرانيا تجد نفسها تتوسلوا الى
الدول الغربيه بغيه تزويدها باسلحه ثقيله
لدعم استعاده اراضيها
اوكرانيا تقول انها بحاجه الى 300 دبابه
غربيه حديثه خلال الربيع القادم
لاستخدامها في المناطق التي استولى الروس
عليها منذ بدايه الحرب فبعد عام تقريبا
منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا تراجع عدد الدبابات التي
يستخدمها الجيش الاوكراني في معركه بسبب
خساره العديد منها في المعارك وخروج
العديد منها من الخدمه بسبب انعدام قطع
الغيار الضروريه
الدبابات الاوكرانيه التي تعود الى مرحله
الستينات والسبعينات من القرن الماضي
تعاني العديد من الاعطال والمشاكل لسوء
الصيانه والاهمال قبل الحرب هذا عدا عن ان
غالبا ما تجر الصيانه في ورش متخصصه بعيده
عن خطوط القتال قبل اندلاع الحرب كانت
اوكرانيا تملكون احواس 900 دبابه من
طرازات المرحله السوفياتيه مثل تي 72 64
وخلال فتره حل في بورصه تبرعت لها بعض دول
الكتله الشرقيه السابقه التي انضمت الى
حلف الناتو بحوالي 200 دبابه من طراز تي
72 وتعتبر بريطانيا هي اول دوله تتبرع
لاوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه حيث منحت 14
دبابه من طراز شالنجر اثنان لاوكرانيا
وفقا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
ورغم ان هذه الدبابات فعاله في ساحه
المعركه لكنها قد تمثل عبء ان لوجسيا على
اوكرانيا لقله عددها واستخدامها لذخائر
خاصه بها لا تتطابق مع مواصفات ذخائر حلف
الناتو او ذا حائر الدبابات الروسيه التي
تملكها اوكرانيا العربيه
معي من موسكو لمزيد من المتابعه هؤلاء هذا
الموضوع طبعا فالجين هاور وهو محلل عسكري
سيفابال اهلا وسهلا بك هل يقلق موسكو بشده
امداد الغرب الكيف بهذه الدبابات مستقبل
سواء ليوبارد او الابرمز وهل ترى موسكو ان
ذلك سيغير من طبيعه الحرب برمتها ام لا
هذا كلام غير صحيح
يبدو ان انا فقدنا الاتصال مع السيد طه لا
نعود اليه بطبيعه الحال همم ضمن سياق هذه
النشره فور جهوز الاتصال مجددا في شان
الاوكراني متصل قال وزير الاقتصاد
السويسري همم ان نقل الاصول الروسيه
المجمده الى اوكرانيا امر غير قانونيه
وذلك بعد ما جمدت بلاده نحو 9 مليارات
دولار كصول روسيه رغم حيادي سويسرا في
سياق ذاته اعلنت في الهند تجميده حسابات
وممتلكات روسيه بقيمه حوالين 190 مليون
يورو مشيره الى ان الاصول على هيئه
ممتلكات واسهم وسيارات ويخوط وطائره
مجددا الى المحلل العسكري بطل في الجمهور
هو معي من موسكو سيطافل كنت قد سالتك الى
اي مدى فعليا موسكو قلقه من امداد الغرب
الكيف بهذه الدبابات هل تعتبر ان هذه
الدبابات ستغير من طبيعه المعركه وبالتالي
هي ترفع الصوت ام لا يعني هذه الدبابات لن
تغير شيء في مجريات الحرب في اوكرانيا
يزود الاسلحه المختلفه انهكرانيا ولكنه لم
يوفرهم او يزودهم دبابات الغربيه وان قريب
سوف يحصل ذلك بلا شك هذا الامر مقلق
للقياده الروسيه
والجيش الروسي
لان هذه الاسلحه
متقدمه
واغلى بها حتى افضل من الاسلحه الروسيه
الدبابه حديثه وخسرت الكثيره منها
وظهور
المعدات الغربيه الثقيله من ضمنها
الدبابات القتاليه قد يكون الخبرا ااا غير
ساره على الاطلاق او غير الشر على الاطلاق
لروسيا خاصه وانا روسيا ليست لديها افضل
الاسلحه الموجهه بالدبابات التي لديها
اوكرانيا
فين ااه
الجانب العلوي من مدرعه ال دبابه وروسيا
ريست لديها مثل هذه الاسلحه وهذه يعني بان
الاسلحه الغربيه ذات المدرعه بشده من
الامام
السهله التخلص منها ولكن هناك اسلحه اخرى
تصل
مثل الاسلحه المضاده الدبابات
وحتى ابعد لي وافضل منها ربما من السويد
واكد عليك المدفعيه الثقيله والصواريخ
بعيده المدى
تزويد هذه الاسلحه لا ثقيله الى اوكرانيا
هذه اسلحه المعاصره يعني بان امل روسيا
بنفادي الجيش الاوكراني من الاسلحه
وانتصاري روسيا بدا يتلى شاب
بامكاني اوكرانيا الاستمرار بالقتال وربما
يكون لديها الافضليه او تفوق على روسيا
على ارض المعركه
الدبابات هو خبر مقلق وغير صار همم موسكو
كيف سترد موسكو يعني الرئيس بوتين قال منذ
عده ايام انه سيتم احراق هذه الدبابات
ونحن نعرف ان موسكو لديها جيش من اقوى
جيوش في العالم اذا كيف سترد
الجيش
الى الان تحتل عدد من المناطق والخطوط
الاماميه مستقره من روسيا حتى تتقدم
ولكنها لم تستخدم الى الان
التشكيلات القتاليه التقليديه للدربت
عليها مع التقدم الدبابات في المقدمه بسبب
الخسائر الفادحه في النصف الاول من الحرب
داخل اوكرانيا وخاصه وانا اوكرانيا
روسيا في المؤخره كثيره منها على
الارجاعها الاخرانيون اذا ما حصلوا على
كميه كبيره
الدبابات الغربيه
ولكن ستكون هناك مشاكل كبيره
وانا امد فسيدوم سكن هناك خساره اكبر من
الطرفين
وتخرج والتهديدات من موسكو بسبب التزويدي
اوكراني بالمزيد من الاسلحه المتقدمه
لجروبات لاطارده اثنين ولا التي ستقود الى
تصعيد جاد لهذه الحرب وربما سته شهور ليس
طاقات اوكرانيا بل حتى اطرافها من اوروبا
العسكري شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
عبر قناه العرب
ايضا
نتنياهو يقيل وزير الصحه والداخليه دراعي
بموجب قرار من المحكمه العليا
اهلا بكم جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه هاجم وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد اللهيان القاده الاوروبيين بعضهم
بانهم لا يتمتعون بخبره كافيه في مجال
الدبلوماسيه بينهم وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه التي تمثل الدبلوماسيه في
بلادها
من ان طهران ربما ستتخذ قرارا بالانسحاب
من معاهده حظر الانتشار النووي وطرد مفتشي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وقال عبد
الله يعني ان اي احتمال غير مستبعد اذا لم
يتم التحرك باتجاه العقلانيه ويصحح
الاوروبيون من موقفهم
رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد باقر قلباف
قال ان بلاده ستعتبر جيوش الدول الاوروبيه
منظمات ارهابيه على حد وصفي وذلك ردا على
موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي من الحرس الثوري
الايراني واضافت قلبه في وكاله تسليم ان
محاولات الغرب ضد الحرس الثوري محكوم
عليها بالفشل
ياتي ذلك بعد مطالب البرلمان الاوروبي في
قرار تبناه مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول
الاعضاء باضافه الحرس الثوري والقوات
التابعه له الى قائمه الارهاب بما في ذلك
قوات البسيج وفيلق القدس
ماما
سيظهر استجابه فوريه
من شانه وضع الحرس الثوري الايراني في
قائمه الارهاب او قوائم العقوبات وسنعترف
بالجيوش الاوروبيه في المنطقه كمجموعات
ومنظمات ارهابيه وسنتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه
لمواجهتها
الايراني وعضو لجنه الامن القومي هدد من
جهاته باستهداف القوات الاجنبيه الموجوده
في الخليج واجزاء اخرى من العالم في حاله
صنف الاتحاد الاوروبي الحارس الثوري كان
منظمه الارهابيه
بالامس عقدنا اجتماع الاستثنائيه لمده
ساعات في لجنه الامن القومي وادي الى بيان
سيصدره البرلمان في حال ذهب قرار البرلمان
الاوروبي الى مجلس الوزراء وتمت الموافقه
عليه وسنوافق على خطنا العاجله في
البرلمان لمواجهه القرار وقد وضع قوه
عسكريه موجوده في دستورنا على قائمه
الارهاب ونحن بدور جميع القوات الاوروبيه
الموجوده في الخليج واجزاء اخرى من العالم
التي تقوم بها الدول الاوروبيه الثلاث
وخاصه امريكا لتاخير خطه العمل الشامل
المشتركه
وفي بلجيكا تجمع المئات في بروكس اللي
يطالبون بالافراج عن مواطنهم المعتقل في
ايران اوليفيا فادنكاستال شقيقه البلجيكي
المحتجز قالت ان عائلتها تحدثت الى
اوليفيا يوم الجمعه الماضي وقد اخبرهم
بانه اوقف اضرابه عن الطعام من اجل البقاء
على قيد الحياه حيث فقد نحو 25 كلغ من
وزنه
ونقلت نتالي عن شقيقها انه معتقلون في
زنزانه
انفراديه مضيفه انه يعاني من متاعب صحيه
مع حرمان من العلاج واضافت ان شقيقها
ابلغها انه لا يحصل على العلاج والدواء
وانه فقد 25 كلغراما خلال اضرابه عن
الطعام كذكر
بعد خمس سنوات قضاها في خدمه اللاجئين
الافغان في ايران
ويجمع المراقبون ان ايران اعتقلت عامل
للاغاثه البلجيكي من اجل الضغط على بروكسل
كي تفرج الاخيره عن الدبلوماسي اسد الله
اسدي الذي حكم عليه بالسجن ل 20 عاما في
العام 20 20 في قضيه مخطط ارهابي فاشل
معي من بروكسل الالي مزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه نور الدين الفريدي نور اهلا
وسهلا بك قبل ان اسالك في التحركات
والقرارات السياسيه المتوقعه من الاتحاد
الاوروبي في اليومين المقبلين لو تطلعنا
لو تضعنا في صوره الاعتصام وهذه التظاهره
التي انت تغطيها من ينظم هذه التظاهره
وابرز المطالب
هي واقفه لي عائلتي واصدقائي اا اولفين دي
كاستل الطلب الذين جاء كانوا درسوا معه في
الجامعه زملائه زملائه في منظمه اطباء من
دون حدود بعض الممثلين الهيئات الاغاثه
لان
دي كاستين ليكتسبوا تجربه طويله عمل في
حقل الانساني 15
عاما في مالي في افغانستان في المخيمات
مخيمات الافغان داخل ايران حيث قضى بين 65
سنوات انها في نهايه العام 2020 ثم عاد في
شهر فبراير من العام الماضي كي يودع
اصدقاءه ويسلم بعض الاغراض ثم يسافر بشكل
نهائي ولكن في في سهر الاخيره قبل سفره
فجاته رجال الشرطه وفي هذه الشقه واعتقلوه
من دون اي سبب بعد ذلك مثل ما اكدت لنا
شقيقته نتالي همم تعتقد ان الحكم الذي صدر
على ايه في ديسمبر الماضي 20 سنه ثم تمت
مضاعفات هذا الحكم الى 40 سنه زائد 40
جلده هو هذا همم ضغط من جانب ايران بعد ان
يئست مرحليا السلطات الايرانيه من عمليه
المقايضه التي والابتزاز التي ارادتها من
خلال اعتقال اوليفي فان دي كاستل مقابل
الافراج عن اسد
هذه الوقفه في الحقيقه ان العائله
واصدقائه‬» بدؤوا في فتره الاخيره يتحركون
في العلني لان نقول في صحه العامه
الدبلوماسيه والحكومه البلجيكيه وقتا
طويلا لكن يبدو ان هذه الوقفه كانت هي
ايضا عباره عن ياتهم من من العمل الحكومه
ومن دورها رغم ان الحكومه
بموجب ما القرار الذي اصدرته المحكمه
الدستوريه بتعطيل معاهده تسليم تبادل
الاسرى بين ايران طيب هل هو نور الان الان
في السياسه هل نتوقع غدا او هل نتوقع غدا
او في الايام القليله المقبله ان يوافق
المجلس الاوروبي على قرار البرلمان بتصنيف
الحرس الثوري الايراني منظمه الارهابيه ام
لا الاوروبيون يتهيبون الموقف تماما ولن
يقدموا على ذلك وفق اخر التوقعات
والمعلومات المتوفره لديك
القرار الذي اتخذه البرلمان الاوروبي
بطلبه تصنيف هذه الحرس الثوري في ضمن
قائمه الارهاب قرار يخص البرلمان فقط
كمؤسسه مستقله
الدبلوماسيه تقودها الدول الاعضاء
الدول الاعضاء تجتمع في المجلس والمجلس لم
يتبنى قرار البرلمان الاوروبي
وجهه نظر
تتقدمها المانيا هولندا جمهوريه التشيك
هاته الدول تريد ان تدرج الحارس الثوري
على قائمه الارهاب
ايضا من ناحيه الدبلوماسيه هناك
دبلوماسيون على مستوى رفيع جدا
هذا القرار سيكون له عواقب وخيمه بالنسبه
لنستقبل الاتفاق النووي
وهذا الكلام
في في همم في المكالمه بينه وبين جوزيف
قبل نهايه الاسبوع
هددت بالانسحاب من معاهده الحد من
الانتشار النووي وايضا بتصنيف القوات
الاوروبيه والجيش الاوروبيه كمنظمات
ارهابيه وهنا كيف سترد اوروبا او كيف ترى
هذا الكلام هل صدر اي موقف عن هذا عن هذا
الكلام الايراني
لم تزد اي مواقف حتى ساعه باعتبار نحن في
نهايه الاسبوع ولكن يوم غد صباح غد يجتمع
وزراء الخارجيه هنا في بروكسل تصنيف
الجيوش الاوروبيه او القوات الاوروبيه ضمن
قوائم الارهاب الايرانيه هاتي مساله
تقريبا يعني هي للراي العامل الايراني
الاستهلاك الداخلي لاكثر الاقل بينما
تهديد ايران بالخروج من محدد حذر الانتشار
روي هذه المساله جديه للغايه وياخذها
سياخذها الاوروبيون بكل جد وحتى ما سمعنا
يعني بشكل مباشر ثنائي همم
الاردني
حتى وان كان هذا الاتفاق بالنسبه لبعض
المساله معقده للغايه وستخلق تعقيدات هذا
لا يعني
ما هو مطروح يوم الاثنين يوم غد ان الحارس
الثوري مدرج في في الاجنده الرسميه مسئلته
يعني يوضح مسالته وتصنيفه الحارس الثوري
في قائمه الارهاب الاوروبيه
مدرجه في اجنده الرسميه
لمجلس وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
من موجود ومطروح بيتسريحات من جانب وزير
خارجه المانيا وهولندا وجمهورتيك في هذا
الشان يبقى انه من الناحيه القانونيه
المساله معقده للغايه اذا اردت هذه الدوله
او تلك ان تصنف الحرس الثوري في قائمه من
بروكسل المراس العربي نور الدين شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
الى شان اخر لان قال رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو وزير
الداخليه والصحه عن حركه شاشات
وذلك عملا بقرار المحكمه الاسرائيليه
وكانت المحكمه قد قضت بالغاء عضويه الوزير
درعي في الحكومه بسبب ادانته المتكرره
بقضايا فساد الملكي ومن المنتظر ان يتم
تعيينه بديلا عن درعي من صفوف حركه شاس
لان السحاب الحركه من الابتلاف يهدد حكومه
ويدرس نتنياهو رغم القرار القضائي ان يبقي
درعي في الحكومه الاسرائيليه الامنيه
المصغره لكن بصفتي مراقب
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
القدس الان مراسل العربيه زياد حلب زياده
اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشره الخامسه اقاله ايه
درعي هل تسحب فتيل الاشتباك وتحل المشكله
ام لا الامور ذاهبه الى مزيد من التصعيد
برايه
لن
وقف المواجهه القائمه بين الائتلاف الحاكم
من جهه وبين نظام القضاء في اسرائيل من
جهه ثانيه على العكس من ذلك سيصب الزيت
على نار هذه المواجهه باعتقاده مراقبين في
اسرائيل اليوم عمليا تلقى نتنياهو رسميا
بعد ان اضطر الى توقيع كتاب الاقاله لاري
درع يتلقى ضربه
التي كانت من المكتبه العليا قبل اربعه
ايام ونفتدها مضطرا وحتى انه في كتاب
الاقاله وهذا غير مسبوق هاجم المحكمه
العليا قال انه ياسف على هذا القرار لانه
كما وصفه ينقلب على اراده النائب
الاسرائيلي في الانتخابات الاخيره همم
راينا بالامس همم مظاهرات 150,000
يتظاهرون في تل ابيب وحيفا والقدس وبائر
السابع سنرى ذلك اسبوعيا ومسا نرى ايضا
محاوله من نتنياهو الحكومه
لتسريع تشريع الخطه التي يقولونها لاصلاح
القضاء والتي يقول كثيرون ان الاضاف
القضاء بمعنى تواتر هذا هذه العمليه
التشريعيه لاضعاف همم القضاء بمعنى اخر
عمليه تغليب قرارات السياسيين اي البرلمان
على قرارات القضاء والمحكمه العليا طيب
زياد الى اي مدى سيظل الامر مضبوطا تحت
سقف المؤسسات في اسرائيل ام لا سيكون
الشارع هو الفيصل يعني حتى تظاهرات بالامس
كانت تظاهرات يعني غير معهوده يعني اكثر
من 100,000 همم نتحدث وهذه في اسرائيل
مساله تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار الى ماذا سيظل
الشارع مضبوطه تحت سقف المؤسسات ام لا كل
طرف سيستخدم الشارع لصالحه وبالتالي حتى
لو ادى ذلك الى الصدام
هناك تحذيرات من دوائر استراتيجيه في
اسرائيل
تحذر بالفعل من عمليا انتقال هذا الامر
بالكامل من المؤسسات اي من البرلمان
والقضاء وال
الكباش السياسي التقليدي الى عمليا
المواجهه في الشارع بين معسكرين معسكر
الائتلاف الذي يريد كما قلنا اضعاف القضاء
لصالح السياسيين ومعسكر المعارضه
التي تريد عمليه منع حدوث ذلك اللافت ربما
طالب في هذا الامر كله هو ان 65% مثلا من
الاسرائيليين يؤيدون همم الغاء عضويه
الدرعيه في الحكومه الاسرائيليه واغلبيه
واضحه ايضا بين الاسرائيليين لا توافق على
الخطه التي يريدها نتنياهو والاحتلاف
اليمني الحاكم ضد القضاء الاسرائيلي لهذا
هناك الكثير من التوتر همم عمليا وحتى ان
الولايات المتحده دخلت على القتل راينا
مستشار الامن القضاء القومي الامريكي همم
يحذر نتنياهو من ان المساس بالقضاء في
اسرائيل قد يضعف قدره واشنطن على حمايه
اسرائيل على ساحه الدوليه ايضا نعم من
القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلب دائما شكرا
لك زياده على كل هذه المتابعه
افادت وكاله رويترز باصابه خمسه اشخاص على
الاقل جرائم في جار في مقر رئيس بلديه
العاصمه الصوماليه مجاديشو عاقبه الشباكات
بين قوات الامن ومسلحين من حركه الشباب
بدورها قالت حركه الشباب انها سيطرت على
مبنى بلديه مقديشو وقتلت حراسه فيما لا
يزالوا القتال متواصلا بين الطرفين وقد
كشفت حركه الشباب منها هجماتها في الاشهر
الاخيره الماضيه ما يعكس قدرتها على
البقاء في المشهد رغم اطلاق الحكومه
الرئيس حسن الشيخ محمود لهجوم ضد مقاتلي
الحركه المواليه لتنظيم القاعده في اغسطس
من العام الماضي
المزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي
من مقاديش الان الصحفي محمد عثمان سوداني
السيد محمد اهلا وسهلا بك همم جديد ما
يجري تحديدا قرب مقر رئيس بلديه العاصمه
وهل فعلا ما زالت الاشتباكات جاريه لانه
حركه الشباب تدعي انها سيطرت على المبنى
صوت اغلاق النار يصنع بشكل متقاطعه ان ان
ان القوات الحكوميه بدات الان تنفذ اخر
عملياتها لملاحظه المصالحين من حركه شباب
الذين يقتحموا المبنى بعد انفجار
انتحاريين امام البوابه الرئيسيه
في العاصمه
الانفجارات قنابل او بعض الرصاصات بشكل
متقدم ولكنه شده الاشتباكات الان تخ ما
يعني ان القوات الخاصه الحكوميه التي
تدخلت لتحرير مقر البلديه بدات عملياتها
الان تؤتي ثمارها اين يتحصن مقاتل حركه
الشباب هل ما زالوا داخل المبنى
الان
تريد
[موسيقى]
على اغلب التقدير بالنزاله يقاتلون في
داخل المبنى ما الذي كان يستهدفه هذا
الهجوم من قبل حركه الشباب سيد محمد اذا
كان لديك معلومات
ارادت حركه الشباب ان ترسلها رساله الى
الحكومه الاسوماليه لان اقدام ما زالت
رافقه وانها قادره على الانتقام بيبدا
العمليات العسكريه التي تقوده الحكومه
والتي ادت الى فقدانها الحركه لسيطره بعض
مناظر استراتيجيه اهمها مدينه على سواحل
المحيط الهنديه الا ان هذه العمليه
العسكريه التي تجريها القوات الحكوميه في
خارج العاصمه ارادت حركه الشباب ان ترسل
الرساله
الناقدامها ما زالترافقه
من مقاديشو الصحفي محمد عثمان السوداني
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه
النشاط الخامس مستمره في هايبر
10 قتلى في اطلاق نار في مدينه تقطنها
غالبيه اسيويه جنوب كاليفورنيا والمشتبه
به ما يزال طليقا
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن محامي للرئيس
الامريكي جوبادل ان وزاره العدل اكتشفت
المزيد من الوثائق السريه اثناء تفتيش
منزل الرئيس
منزل الرئيس الامريكي في دلاوير اسفر عن
العثور على ست»
لعنه الوثائق السريه لا تزالت لاحقا
الرئيس الامريكي جوبايلي
36 عثر عليها هذه المره في منزل بايدين
البحث استمرق الرابط اثني عشر ساعه وشملت
كل اماكن العمل والمعيشه والتخزين في
المنزل لحظه غياب بيض وزوجته اثناء
التفتيش الوثائق الست عود لفتره عضويته في
مجلس الشيوخ واخرى اثناء توليه منصب نائب
الرئيس باراك اوباما تضاف الوثائق الست
الى وثائق اخرى عثر عليها في مقر اقامه
بعيد في الثانيه عشر من الشعر الجاري
ووثائق اخرى عثر عليها في مكتبه السابق في
مركز ابحاث بوشنطن
وثيقه اخرى تضع الديمقراطيين في موقف لا
يحسدون عليه بعد ان وجهه كثيرا من
الانتقادات الى الرئيس السابق الجمهوري
دونالد ترامب الذي يخضع هو الاخر لتحقيق
قضائي الاحتفاضه باكثر من مئه وثيقه سريه
على الرغم من مغادرته واشنطن عام 2021 اما
الرئيس فيقف امام اسئله ملحه تدور حول تلك
الوثائق فحواها ومدى خطورتها عصام عبد
السلام العربيه
اقل رئيس البرازيلي لويس سيلفا قال قائد
الجيش بعد احداث الثامن من يناير التي
تخللها اعمال تخريب ونهب لمقار السلطه في
برازيليا نفذها مؤيدون للرئيس السابق جاي
يرقص سينارو رفضوا هزيمته الانتخابيه
وسيحل محل قائد الجيش المقال الجنرال
توماس روبيرو بافيا القائد العسكري للجنوب
الشرقي وفقا لمصادر في الرئاسه وتعتبروا
العلاقه مع القوات المسلحه واحده من اكبر
التحديات التي يواجهها الولد
الذي سيتوجه الى الارجنتين للالتقاء
بحليفه الرئيس البرتو فرنانديز وكذلك
نظرائه في المنطقه خلال مشاركته في قمه
سلاح
ويعتبر خبراء ان امريكا اللاتينيه ستشكل
المرحله الاولى من اعاده علاقات البرازيل
بالخارج قبل زياره المستشار الالماني الى
برازيليا في 30 من يناير تعقبها زياره الى
واشنطن حيث يلتقي نظيره الامريكي
في العاشر من فبراير
افادت الشرطه الامريكيه بمقتل 10 اشخاص
واصابه 10 اخرين في حادث اطلاق نار بمدينه
مونتيري بارك في ولايه كاليفورنيا ذات
الاغلبيه الاسيويه
واكدت الشرطه ان المشتبه بها في تنفيذ
الحادث مازال الطريقا الى ان العمليه تمت
اثناء احتفالات بالعام القمري الصيني
الجديد في ما لم تكشف حتى الان عن الدوافع
وراء ذلك
كيف تحقيق صحيفه الجاردين البريطانيه عن
اختفاء العاشرات من الاطفال طالبين اللجوء
في بريطانيا بظروف غامضه وسط انباء عن
اختطافهم من قبل عصابات اجراميه وقد تم
اختطاف الاطفال بحسب الصحيفه من فندق
تديره وزاره الداخليه بمدينه برايتون
باقليم جنوب شرق بريطانيا في نمط يبدو انه
يتكرر عبر الساحل الجنوبي للمملكه وقد عاش
حوالي 600 طفل من طالب اللجوء بدون ذويهم
في فندق تديره وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه
كما ذكرنا وقد تم الابلاغ عن اختفاء مئه
وست 136 منهم فيما لا يزال اكثر من نصف
هؤلاء اي ما يعادل 79 طفلا في عداد
المفقوده
اذهب الى لندن لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم اليه من هناك احمد السعدون
وهو الخبير القانوني في شؤون الهجره
واللجوء استاذ احمد اهلا وسهلا بك الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه هل يعقل حوالي
139 طفلا اما مخطوفا او مفقودا من قبل
عصابات اجراميه وكان هؤلاء يسكنون في
مباني تابعه لوزاره الداخليه البريطانيه
هل يعقل
كل الشكر والامتنان زميل طالب وشكر موصول
لكادر قناه العربيه على التغطيه طبعا يعني
هذا الامر همم يعني همم انا حاليا اشعر
بالصدمه يعني من هذا الخبر علما انه صحيح
هي تحظى بسمعه طيبه ولها مصداقيه في في
وسط البريطاني والاعلام البريطاني في نفس
الوقت هذا الخبر لو يكون في العراق في
سوريا في الصومال في اي دوله لربما ما
استغرب لكن ان يحصل في بريطانيا حقيقه
يعني جدا همم يثير القلق في نفس الوقت همم
اريد فكره سريعه حول انه طالبيه اليوتيوب
تحت سن القانوني عند وصولهم الى الاراضي
البريطانيه سوف يخضعون الى ما يسمى
بالسوشل سيرفس اي الرعايه الاجتماعيه
تحديدا في نفس الوقت هذه المراكز تكون
فيها همم حتى الموظفين هم يعني همم
حاليا بعنايه حتى سجلهم الامني يكون همم
لا ليس عليه اي شائبه في نفس الوقت ما حصل
انه هذه المنظمات ان صح التقرير يعني اكرر
مره اخرى لانه يعتبر خرق في في في في في
في القوانين وخرق كبير لجهاز اسكتلنديارد
الشرطه البريطانيه تحديدا هي مسؤوله عن عن
عن المواطن البريطاني والمقيمين لو صح هذا
التقرير لانه هذه المنظمه ما عملت هذا
الحادث بليله الوضحاء ان ما كان هناك
لربما اشهر معده لخطف هؤلاء هذه منظمات
الجار بالبشر هي عديمه الضمير همم
بالنهايه هي الربح الحقيقي همم
لا شيء اكثر من هذا في نفس الوقت الان ال-
الحكومه البريطانيه تحديدا
اذا الجاري مع تقول الجاردي هو الكلام ليس
لي للجاردين ان الحكومه البريطانيه تم
تحذيره واكثر من مره من عمليات خطف
الاطفال من قبل هذه العصابات الاجراميه
لكنها لم تحرك او لم تتحرك بالشكل المطلوب
او لم تحرك ساكنه الا يجعل الحكومه
البريطانيه في موقف صعب جدا
من دون شيك موقف صعب في نفس الوقت همم
يعني غير خافي عن حظرتك بريطانيا تحديدا
يعني من دخولك الى المطار ان كان المطار
هيثروقات همم اللي زاير بريطانيا وعنده
انطلاع هو محكومه بنظام سي سي تي في نظام
تقني امني كبير مراقبه همم
في شوارع البريطانيه وفي كل مؤسساتها فما
ممكن هذه المنظمه تتجرا للقيام بهذا العمل
وحتى هي منطقيا انخطف 120 130 اقل اكثر
يعتبر مساله صعبه
يعني لو تحسبها حسابات
يعني رياضيه قانونيه امنيه هذا كيف تم وكم
عدد الاشخاص اللي يواجهه في نفس الوقت همم
حتى همم اعتقد معلومه دقيقه الفنادق هي لا
تخضع الى حمايه الشرطه البريطانيه هناك
خضع الى اداره الفندق
لكن الماينر هؤلاء الاطفال لهم ناس
متخصصين لمتابعتهم في حاله مراجاهتهم الى
الطبيب الى الى مكاتب المحاماه الى
المدرسه هذا الامر كلش يعني لابد ان يصل
همم متلقي المهم ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
لندن احمد سعدون الخبير القانوني في شؤون
الهجره واللجوء شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه نشاط الخامسه المفصله من العربيه
انتهت اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]